the global police raids have included
the italian mafia
asian crime syndicates drugs cartels and
illegal motorcycle gangs
more than 800 arrests in 16 different
countries
the criminal gangs thought that their
communications were encrypted and secure
what they didn't know
was that the devices called anom had
been developed by the fbi
in collaboration with australian and
european police the criminals using
these devices believed they were
secretly planning crimes
far beneath the radar of law enforcement
but in reality
the criminals were not underneath the
radar they were on it
criminal gangs today rely on secure
digital communication
and the fbi plan was a real slow burner
the first
handful of compromised and non-devices
were quietly supplied to criminals in
australia around 18 months ago
and built up a solid reputation among
the criminal underworld
then when law enforcement knocked out
the rival encro chat and sky ecc
networks earlier this year
more than twelve thousand of the
compromised anom devices were in
circulation all around the globe
multi-million dollar international crime
empires were now
openly visible to the fbi and police on
anna
criminal communicated in 45 languages
about things like trafficking in drugs
arms
and explosive ram raid atm gas attacks
armed robberies and last but not least
contract killings
the coordinated raids around the globe
have found more than 32 tons of various
illegal drugs
hundreds of firearms and weapons have
been recovered and nearly 150 million
dollars in cash and cryptocurrency has
been seized
it's the third mobile phone encrypted
mobile phone network to be compromised
by law enforcement within a very short
period of time
and i expect others are coming so
who can you trust there are still
criminal networks in existence
there are other illicit communications
networks still operating
but when police chiefs call this
operation a watershed moment in global
law enforcement
it's difficult to disagree paul brennan
al jazeera
is joining us from washington d.c and we
heard from the fbi a little earlier on
what more did we learn about this
operation
well we learned about the origins of it
and that's back in 2015 in
san diego which is why the fbi held that
news conference in that city
then there were arrests made of
manufacturers of an online
application that was being used by
criminals with the knowledge of those
who designed it
those executives of the company that did
that were arrested
and then in subsequent months a number
of other similar companies
were closed down and the fbi together
with australian police
realized that there was a vacuum in the
market and hence they developed this app
called anang which was first applied
in australia this would appear to be
because of
privacy concerns and because u.s law
enforcement
had to get all the warrants in place to
be able to carry out
what is essentially uh surveillance on
these
criminal entities or alleged criminal
entities so it began in australia ran
out as a test then
and it was one single alleged criminal
who was given the first device he
had lived in australia at the time then
moved subsequently to turkey
but over subsequent months that device
or the application
was provided to more and more criminal
organizations
until it reached about 12 000
individuals working for some
300 criminal syndicates so this was a
massive
slow operation and the only reason it
would appear to have come
to light now is because one of the
search warrants
ended so the paper was revealed in court
clearly the fbi and other law
enforcement agencies
concerned now that the criminals would
know about this particular sting
and hence around the world the facts
have now been made public
mike the the fbi is telling this as a
great success but there's also a
conversation going on about the
tactics used by the fbi and whether
privacy was breached
well certainly it is as the fbi says
probably
the greatest criminal sting operation in
living memory but there are those issues
of privacy that defendants are likely
to be going into now the fbi
had indicated that it had taken legal
uh precautions every single step of the
way and this is why it started in
australia it would appear
to allow the fbi to be able to get its
legal ducks in a row so to speak
to be able to get the search warrants
all the necessary legal requirements
to do what is essentially hidden
surveillance
of individuals and organizations that
the fbi
had completely entrapped in terms of
what they were doing so there will be
discussion no doubt it will come before
the courts when the
uh defendants appear before the courts
we do know as well
that a grand jury has been empaneled
within the united states 18 individuals
will appeal before that grand jury now
in those discussions which are of course
secret
there's likely to be a lot of debate
about privacy concerns
despite the fbi's uh saying that this is
a
major major achievement thank you so
much mikana reporting from washington
d.c